Якби президентські вибори відбулися нині, то за Зеленського
проголосувало б на третину менше українців, ніж торік.
З рекордних 73 відсотків виборців,
які підтримали Зеленського у другому турі,
президент розгубив за перший рік на посаді значну частину прихильників.
Тим не менше підтримка у президента все ще дуже висока:
за різними опитуваннями, від 40 до 50 відсотків.
DW поспілкувалася з українцями, які торік голосували за Зеленського.
Чи зробили б вони це ще раз?
Я точно проголосував би.
Тому що загалом так, як рухаються сьогодні справи в державі,
мене задовольняє.
У нас чудова синхронізація роботи між урядом, президентом і парламентом.
Це забезпечує швидкі рішення.
Протягом першого року ми бачимо
дуже яскравий прорив саме в цифровій індустрії.
Ми бачимо,
що кількість ІТ-розробників в Україні подвоюється кожні 3 роки.
Костянтина Євтушенка, одного з керівників інноваційного парку Unit city,
переконав той прогрес, який Україна зробила за цей рік в галузі цифрової трансформації:
запровадили електронні паспорти, електронні права водія,
різні зручні для громадян додатки,
які допомагають уникати чиновницьку бюрократію.
Саме завдяки цим змінам, каже він, українські стартапи
змогли швидко переорієнтувати свої ресурси
і стати в нагоді під час пандемії коронавірусу,
друкуючи майже цілодобово на 3D-принтерах захисні щитки для лікарів.
Як складно працювати в умовах криз, знає військова волонтерка Раїса Шматко.
Торік вона покладала на Зеленського надії
як на нову людину в політиці, яка пообіцяла мир на Донбасі.
Але за рік розчарувалася в президенті, і не лише через сумнівні ініціативи щодо Донбасу
чи провальне, на її погляд, розслідування справ Майдану.
Якби зараз відбулися вибори - ні.
Чому? Тому що
Це закони про землю, про ринок землі...
Але не в цих умовах, не у воюючій країні.
Це не тільки земля - це і недоторканність.
Де вона, та недоторканість?
Ви почитайте той закон.
Це Роттердам плюс.
У нас не те, що стали меншими комунальні платежі, а вони збільшилися
і далі будуть зростати.
Це непокаране зло Майдану.
Це повернення, я би навіть сказала, реванш "регіоналів" в Україні.
В Україні будуть стріляти лише салютами на свята.
Ця обіцянка з передвиборчої програми Зеленського рік тому
переконала і військового капелана з Маріуполя  Альберта Хомяка.
Я би за Зеленського не проголосував знову.
Ця ситуація, яка відбувається на Донбасі з розведенням військ…
Більше за все боюся цього розведення,
тому що якщо в Широкине, де Маріуполь, відведуть війська
на кілометр-два,
окупанти візьмуть висоту перед Маріуполем.
А хто бере висоту, той контролює місто.
Я в вікно бачу, як кожен день стріляють.
Ще й як стріляють, в нас вікна трясуться!
А кажуть, що в нас війни немає, в нас мир, розведення…
Поетеса Мартіна Макеєва каже, що їй стало комфортніше жити в Україні,
займатися бізнесом, кілька місяців тому оформила ФОП
і добре продає свої книжки.
Жінка зізнається, що "не є великим експертом у великій політиці",
але проголосувала би за Зеленського і тепер.
Проголосувала би, звісно.
З точки зору команди Зеленського,
звісно, є і якісь,можливо, мінуси.
Тому що молоді - дорівнює недосвідчені.
І команда недосвідчена.
У неї є помилки.
Але те, що зменшилася корупція
- це однозначно.
Те, що Зеленський продемонстрував,
що він не традиційний такий хапуга,
як ми звикли бачити владу в Україні,
це однозначно…
Я вважаю, що їм треба дати
ще трохи часу і шанс.
А от харківський підприємець
Валерій Нестерук вважає,
що Зеленський поступово втрачає підтримку дрібних та середніх підприємців.
Каже, що голосуючи торік за Зеленського, сподівався, що "слуги народу",
на відміну від політиків старого зразка,
не будуть працювати в інтересах олігархів,
що владу поміняють не лише в Києві, а й у регіонах.
Натомість турборежим монобільшості у парламенті
видав на-гора податкові закони,
які вкотре лише закручують гайки дрібному та середньому бізнесу.
В жодному разі я би за нього не голосував.
Основна проблема - некомпетентність цих людей,
як у Верховній Раді, так і в Кабміні, які зайшли.
Це просто низький рівень компетентності.
Основне, що він обіцяв - це побороти корупцію.
Це основний "біч" України.
Це те зло, яке знищує Україну як державу.
Його головний лозунг був: прийде весна - будемо саджати…
Друга весна прийшла, і не те
щоб нікого не посадили,
а навпаки - корупція ще більше процвітає, ніж раніше.
Через рік після обрання Зеленського його колишні і теперішні прихильники
сходяться в одному: часу, щоб навчатися
керувати державою, у Зе-команди вже немає.
У наступні чотири роки Зеленський має продемонструвати,
що пройшовши рік "бойового хрещення" при владі,
він здатний вивести країну
з економічної і соціальної кризи,
яка нині посилюється на тлі епідемії коронавірусу.
І що суспільство відчує обіцяне Зеленським
"кожен є президентом України".
Поки йому нерідко закидають відсутність дискусії з суспільством.